hello and welcome to the agenda we're
here in Strasbourg where MEP are busy at
work but let's take a look at what's
happening next week and we head back to
Brussels satnavs can be a real blessing
if you are directionally challenged but
they can also be a real pain in the neck
the industry committee is set to vote on
Wednesday on plans for two new satellite
navigation systems Galileo and egnos and
with it we won't be dependent on
American Chinese or Russian technology
here's to the future new legislation is
on the cards to help us better manage
risks and returns give this restore
consumer confidence in financial markets
and make is richer beyond our wildest
dream ok maybe not find out more when
the economic and Monetary Affairs
Committee meets on tuesday first there
was a pap breast implant scandal and
then we learnt that a french
manufacturer of hip replacement sarabear
had sold non-certified prosthetic limbs
to french hospitals preventing another
pap disaster will be top of the agendas
Parliament's health committee will vote
on a draft report on medical devices on
Wednesday last year's winners were two
Iranian activists the sakharov prize of
freedom of thought is Parliament's not
to those who stand up for human rights
of democracy find out on Monday who made
this year's a short list at a quick
mention of Parliament's crime committee
they will make their final vote on a
draft report an organized crime
corruption and money laundering on
Tuesday
and that's what we have for this agenda
take care and enjoy the week